tour de france you know this is coming
in hot oh this is funny
a woman is standing there with a sign
for her grandma her grandpa holds it out
in front of
uh what they call the peloton erasers
yeah and then
causes arguably the biggest crash in
tour de france history
this [ __ ] gotta work for the wwe
because her clothesline was unbelievable
it looks like when they get hit with the
chair she just holds the sign out
somebody's bike hits it and it's like a
massive pack of fire
riders yeah one guy topples and then
just a domino effect of everybody else
following is
from one side getting stuck out also the
sign keep in mind it's just a piece of
car cardboard it's her arm
that stops a bike from moving and makes
the guy fall
you guys spun around her arm like his
chin got caught
i thought he's gonna land back on what
an absolute [ __ ]
yeah what about they need steroids if he
was on steroids
if he was using performance enhancing
drugs ripped off he would have held her
arm in
his mouth like a bulldog that's amazing
a 100 that is the argument for
performance-enhancing drugs back in
biking
isn't that exactly what would happen in
france just one arm takes out the whole
[ __ ] race
yeah it didn't make me get slapped by
your prime minister yeah it's so soft
right inmate bikers look like some real
a whole army bro yeah
do you remember that one time when when
a biker said uh i don't know there was
like a fight and then someone threw the
person off the bridge
wait what i think i don't know if it was
tour de france but it was some bike race
and they were beefing or something like
that and he just threw either the bike
off the bridge or the person
very different circumstances yeah i
couldn't believe either yeah [ __ ] i
i might be mixing the [ __ ] up anyway
this [ __ ] is serious bro did you watch
some mob movies yeah i think
i remember the kentucky derby they put
the horse
and it was really motivational getting
what the guy is amazing how you can
motivate people through blood
yeah uh but yeah this [ __ ] is serious
we need to interview her we need her on
flagrant too apparently she fled the
country
yeah no one can find her apparently she
need to be a matador bro
and just have that arm like that and
watch the ball run into it and just go
unconscious immediately
concussed dude i would love to know the
conversation was with her grandparents
like what it said was a sign that says
hi grandma hi
grandpa and jeff wonder if she if she
talks to them and they're like yeah we
saw
there's a big crash in the tour de
france yeah whoa that's weird i haven't
heard about that
well i guess you got the message it's
just so crazy
dude there's no way her grandparents are
even watching
no [ __ ] well maybe it's big in france oh
maybe
but even then bro just call them
you can't just call your grand hey look
at tv i'm here yeah i just called my
grandma normally yeah
yeah or something but yeah what do you
think like do you think they noticed her
like could you see her face in the video
and all
right no i think she's wearing like
sunglasses like she's disguised a bit oh
maybe she did it on purpose
oh uh it's magazine yeah
yeah yeah man yeah he killed a bunch of
cycling he's going to take out the
cyclist
he was tired of it he was tired of the
corruption and cycling yeah he was tired
it was a shot at the news cycle
oh that's what i'm saying
that was good hey it's not me it's
mcafee oh
okay that's right that's right credit
where credit is served question how does
that [ __ ] work
does that race ever stop what the tour
de france yeah
i think like is it like one day you race
for a while they do multiple days
yeah it's stages it's 14 days or
something like that and that's your
total time
so you could lose a bunch of the stages
but if your total time is
okay okay yeah matter of fact it's
probably like not beneficial to being
first
because you can't coast off of the uh
what is the
turn it's not the jet stream but like
lift or whatever this is how mark was
cheating in the go-kart
what did i do because he was just
knocking us into the wall and [ __ ] like
that and he's like oh i won i got the
best one
race that girl had the sign you guys hit
it yeah yeah
that's how french people do french
they're very aggressive when it comes to
the racing yeah
100 make sense of [ __ ] this makes sense
though yeah and but don't worry the
people see soon yeah my favorite lost
every time he's like oh i got the best
one lap i got the best one
the best time and i've won absolutely
[ __ ] absolutely
[Applause]